In order to fully understand monitoring,
first, one must have a better understanding
of what quality systems are, and what are
their purposes. Quality control systems are
the operational techniques and activities
undertaken to verify the requirements for
the quality of trial related activities.
Monitoring is a part of the QC activity.
Monitoring activities are undertaken
by the trial members themselves.
Audit is an inspection undertaken by personnel
independent of trial in accordance with the
protocol of the study’s standard operating
procedures or SOPs. It is part of a QA activity.
A monitor is an individual employed by a
pharmaceutical or medical device manufacturer by
a contract research organization, usually acting
on a sponsor’s behalf or by an academic Institute
conducting clinical trials. Some of the
major responsibilities of the monitor are:
• assuring the protection of the rights,
safety and well-being of human study subjects.
• to analyze and evaluate clinical data.
• to ensure investigator and site compliance
with the study drug protocol, overall
clinical objectives, FDA regulations,
ICH guidelines and good clinical practice.
• help in the study site selection
process
• initiate
and eventually close out clinical study sites
• to monitor the progress of clinical study sites
participating in a clinical study
• to ensure that protocol is
followed and data is reported accurately
• to make certain that the scientific integrity
of the data collected is protected and verified
• to assure that adverse events are correctly
documented and reported, review all case report
forms and compare them to source documents
Auditing is the systematic and independent
examination of trial related activities in
documents to determine whether the evaluated trial
related activities were conducted and whether
the data was recorded, analyzed and accurately
reported according to the protocol. The most cited
clinical trial areas during audits include:
• adverse event review and reporting
• closure of study or lapse
• approvals while studying
related activities which are still ongoing
• informed consent process and documentation
• drug or device accountability
• protocol adherence
Inspection is the act by a regulatory authority
or authorities of conducting an official review
of documents, facilities, records and any other
resources that are deemed by the authorities to
be related to the clinical trial, and that may be
located at the site of the trial, at the sponsors
or CRO’s facilities, or at other establishments
deemed appropriate by the regulatory authorities.
The inspections consist of site visits to the
organization and where appropriate, selected
clinical investigator sites. The inspection
starts with an opening meeting where the lead
inspector usually outlines the scope and purpose
of the inspection, confirms the inspection plan,
and introduces the inspectors upon completion of
the inspection process. If inspectors find issues
related to the clinical trial process, certain
measures should be taken. Here are a few examples:
• protocol non-compliance
• inadequate or inaccurate records
• informed consent issues
• adverse event reporting
Some of the major differences
between an audit and inspection are:
• in audit, inspectors are employed by the
company who work for active clinical quality
assurance function (e.g. sponsor, CRO and etc)
• an audit is done to ensure that the site
complies with protocol, SOP, GCP and
applicable regulatory requirement
• in inspection, inspectors are employed
by government through the agency of the
regulatory or competent authority (e.g. FDA)
• an inspection is done to ensure the trial
related obligations and acceptability
of resultant clinical data is relevant